we asked you to vote for the 2017 movie
she wanted us to make an honest trailer
for now you're number three choice
floats to today's episode is brought to
you by turbo tax there's nothing to be
afraid of from the twisted mind of
Stephen King master of horror suspense
and really inconsistent movie
adaptations people really should learn
to keep their hands to themselves comes
the scary clown movie that was so scary
it killed the actual clown industry
thank you so much life in Derry Maine
has its ups and clowns because Pennywise
is lurking in the gutter and this piece
of it will eat you alive unless each
feeds on people's fear tasty tasty
beautiful field or maybe eat you alive
and feeds on your fear feed on your fear
or maybe you'll just scare you real bad
and leave you alone it's kind of muddled
rule of thumb main characters get
spooked everyone else's clown food
journey to the ideally child murder
capital of America and meet a losers
club full of Goonies and Lost Boys kids
who'd beat One Direction fans in a
screaming contest there's the leader the
sick one the bookworm the kid from
stranger things in glasses the girl one
and also the other two whose character
development got cut for time Mike
doesn't say a word for 45 minutes of
screen time do you really want to turn
one of the books main characters into
Phil Winston of the movie really okay
movie you're the movie thrill as each
child's fear preys on them in a unique
form just try not to notice that it
preys on them in the exact same way
where the kid will go off on their own
notice something out of the ordinary
look like a nice boy and slowly walk
towards it
hello until a monster pops out
[Music]
oh no you can just say nope and walk the
other way right problem solved ride the
wave of nostalgia that's still sweeping
Hollywood and get your required dose of
80's pop culture like New Kids on the
Block bullets that terrible street
fighter game that time in school where
girls have started puberty but boys are
still years off in class not knowing how
aids works and of course the kid from
stranger things which makes you
nostalgic for stranger things which
makes you nostalgic for the 80s which
makes you nostalgic for Stephen King's
it and the circle is complete feast on
this enjoyable movie adaptation of a
popular TV adaptation of a creepy book
that managed to out creep Tim Curry and
wisely punted the boring adult stuff
that no one remembers to the sequel Plus
made some radical departures from the
original book ditching the 50s era that
preteen gangbang scene and the
appearance of Maturin the god turtle who
teaches Billy how to perform the magic
ritual of chewed hew guys made that one
up no really that's in there Wow make
sense they cut it but at the same time I
kind of want to see that so enjoy a
horrifying trip down memory lane
that cements clowns as a scariest
childhood thing since dolls and puppets
making boatloads of cash for everyone
involved and guarantees that somebody
somewhere just greenlit a Maximum
Overdrive remake
[Music]
I don't know if I'm ready for another
Stephen King assualt you guys it's gonna
be a bumpy ride starring dorky Pig way
more important in Chapter two Kyle
Broflovski why run a joke when your real
name is Finn wolfhard
og chug chug Sheldon just as for bath
but doctor I am Pagliacci and the insane
clown posse
Stephen King's
[Music]
Batman came out on June 23rd and lethal
weapon 2 came out on July 7th so dare
either gets movies really early school
gets out really late or they wanted to
give us one more hit of that sweet sweet
nostalgia this episode was brought to
you by turbo tax there's nothing to be
afraid of my name is penny wise the
dancing clown do you want a balloon be
beat Ritchie we all float down here
you'll flow to their gazebos